[Music]
it is the best-selling book in history
no volume ever written has been more
loved and quoted and its words sometimes
simple and sometimes mysterious should
always be studied carefully it is the
bible the word of god
welcome to bible answers live providing
accurate and practical answers to all
your bible questions
our phone lines are open if you have a
bible related question give us a call
now at 800 god says that's 800-463-7297
now here's your host from amazing facts
international pastor doug batchelor
hello friends would you like to hear an
amazing fact
if you want to have a dazzling dinner
the most expensive restaurant in the
world is sublimotion in ibiza spain
at over two thousand dollars per person
a maximum of 12 guests sit around one
table and receive 15 courses of
delicious food plus dessert prepared by
some of the world's best chefs
of course the portions are small or
you'd be uncomfortably stuffed
the meal is much more than food the
entire room and table is a high
definition screen making it an immersive
experience
some courses drop from the ceiling and
desserts hover above the table
the atmosphere and music of the room
will change over the course of the night
the result is a spectacular three-hour
banquet that takes guests on a
sensational journey from a vivid coral
reef beneath the ocean to fantasy
forests to a futuristic dinner where
friends and guests put on these special
3d goggles
and i'm wondering if they can do vegan
do you know the bible says there's one
dinner that's even more expensive and
you've been invited for free
isn't that incredible
yeah i was i'm thinking i'm not taking
my wife there for
well yeah you'd probably have to take
out a loan to take her to dinner yeah i
went on the website and i noticed they
said they don't do a taco take home
you can't bring a doggy bag yeah
so that's amazing yeah
what is that free
that free dinner
that free celebration yeah i kind of set
that up the bible tells us that the best
supper in the world and the most
expensive supper in the world of course
it's expensive because it costs the life
of god's son
but it's free for us in that he's giving
it as a gift so it's very expensive and
it's called the marriage supper of the
lamb and you can read about that in
revelation 19 verse 6. this is the last
book of the bible some of the last
chapters
and i heard as it was a voice of a great
multitude
and the sound of many waters
and the sound of mighty thundering
saying
hallelujah for the lord god omnipotent
reigns let us be glad and rejoice and
give him glory for the marriage supper
of the lamb has come and his wife has
made herself ready
and to her it was granted to be arrayed
in fine linen clean and bright for the
fine linen is the righteous acts of the
saints
and then he said to me
write
blessed are those who are called to the
marriage supper of the lamb
and he said these are the true sayings
of god this is a message directly from
the angels
to the apostle john telling about this
dinner of all dinners
that will eat and jesus even says and i
will come and serve you amen so it's
it's almost incomprehensible yes it's
it's to think that at that moment we
should be serving him for all he's done
for us
and again it shows the level of humility
of god even when you know when he was on
earth you could kind of understand the
condescension of god that he would say i
want to be an example of how you serve
each other but even now that he's in
heaven
the idea that he said
i'm i'm your brother and i want to serve
you and
i'm guessing that somewhere on the table
they're going to have some of the tree
of life
maybe a fruit cocktail with 144 000
different
samplers
yeah so i want to be at that dinner and
by the way friends uh we have a free
offer tonight that uh you can ask for
that will tell you how you can get your
ticket to that special restaurant yeah
so the free offer if you go
1-800-835-6747
it's uh a free offer number 156 the high
cost of the cross
right so if you're available here in
north america and u.s territories just
call that number 1-800-835-6747
offer number 156 and we will send that
to you for free so call us you know i
probably should have said something uh
pastor john ross is not here tonight we
gave him the night off because he's
at his
mother-in-law's birthday party and if
you miss that you're in trouble yeah and
so i'm really glad that pastor carlos
munoz is here with us both evangelists
and the director of our man amazing
facts evangelism training program and
he's a well-versed expert in scripture
so we're very comfortable working
together we've we've did meetings
together in puerto rico where you're
from and
yeah this is our first time doing bal
together that's right you've been here
before but with john we're glad that
you're uh leading out and maybe before
we go to the phones you could lead us in
prayer sure let's have a word of prayer
father we thank you again for a
beautiful day of life and thank you for
this opportunity to come together and
spend time in your word answering bible
questions and so we just ask for
your divine discernment and wisdom and
with us and with everybody that's
calling and listening also may your
spirit guide us to truth and to live by
truth and so we thank you father and we
ask this in jesus name amen amen
all right so we have the first question
here is from anthony in new york anthony
good evening you're on the air
anthony might have been muted but you're
on can you hear us yes
yes i was muted good evening friends how
are you doing doing great right now
you're talking to two new yorkers right
now so we we could probably understand
each other without a translator
my question tonight is um
why did uh
nineveh
get a warning
to repent or be destroyed but it appears
that sodom and gomorrah didn't
okay good question
and a lot of people don't realize sodom
and gomorrah did get a warning
pastor carlos might look it up for me
but when lot and his family were carried
off by the king shettel laomer from the
north there was a judgment that came on
sodom gomorrah abraham went out and he
saved them
and so he saved them and this was to you
know urge them to repent of their sins
because they had nearly been destroyed
but through abraham's intercession and
god's mercy they were given another
chance
when the judgment finally came
in is it genesis
19 19 yeah
then uh well that was because they'd run
out of their you know god said they'd
push the envelope too far
yep
so they were actually warned and they
were you know given kind of a
chastisement warning them to turn from
their wicked ways and they didn't and
nineveh was warned they repented but
later on they went back into their
wicked ways the judgment came i think it
was a
flood and fire and wars it just
destroyed the city
very good does that help a little
anthony
yes it does thank you very much i
appreciate that thank you all right
thank you anthony
next we have uh jesus from palm bay
florida jesus you're on the air my guess
is it's jesus but you would know that
and are you there jesus hey
yeah yeah hey pastors it is jesus um
but i usually get both
um
so my question today is
when
witnessing to other denominations
how should we witness when it comes to
doctrines and differences between
doctrines all right that's a good
question
you know uh first thing is if you're if
you're talking to people um
uh you know from a differing
denomination
you know clearly everybody is part of a
denomination because they believe
certain things that are sensitive to
their beliefs
first thing you want to do is be winsome
find common ground
show them that you love and respect them
even though you may disagree
it's okay to disagree without being
disagreeable
and
then you might you know put them in a
question in a position where you're
saying look help me understand instead
of saying you know what you believe
about the trinity what you believe about
the res
it's all wrong or what you believe about
tongues it's all wrong instead of coming
off as an attack
you can come off and say
help me understand better what it is you
believe
and
then you kind of question them when they
read something they say now where's the
verse for that
and so you do it in more of a you know a
winsome uh teaching way
as opposed to clubbing a person with
your
opinions
yeah and you always wanna everything
that you share with people always have
your bible verse your foundation so that
they see that it's not your opinion
that you're basing it off of scripture
right
yeah i i
i did a debate with another pastor it
was a friendly debate
and uh then afterwards someone brought
to my attention
they said doug you said well i believe
and you should have said the bible says
and i looked at that and i thought you
know that's right i had all the
scriptures and it said i said i was
saying well you believe this and i
believe this and i should have said well
the bible says this because that's the
final word
in all of that
and uh yeah we appreciate your calling
jesus
by the way i don't know if we ever gave
out the number you know some callers
popped up and we just dove right in but
if you would like to be tonight part of
tonight's program there are lines open
and as a free phone call just call 800
god says
that's 800-463-7297
not only are we on radio stations both
satellite and land-based stations around
the country but we are streaming this
live if you want to watch what's
happening here in the studio we're on
amazing facts television we're on
facebook that's the amazing facts
facebook page we're on the doug
batchelor facebook page
and maybe even youtube but um so you can
watch you can listen and call in with
your questions yeah all right so let's
look at
we have a question here this is jerry
from texas jerry you are live
hey guys good evening thanks for taking
my question i have two texts in genesis
and the first text is genesis
27-30 and this is uh
kind of a terrible time when dinah
dina went into the the land of the
kingdom that they were they were staying
and
shechem fell in love with dina and
he took advantage of her
and of course the brothers didn't like
it
and
then
they i don't know which one made a
proposal that we we would be one people
you'll give us your job sounds like it
was either simeon or levi we're not sure
we have simi and libya were the ones
that
uh killed them
and
so that was a very thing though jacob
said you make a stink of me and the
people you know and then jacob moved on
and they took their women their children
and their
uh
cattle and all their physicians
and
where are those individuals in genesis
46 6
when jacob goes down to israel i see no
mention of them of the 70 that went down
to egypt land
you know the seventy that are mentioned
i know this may sound terrible but the
seventy that are mentioned were all
family members that are descendants of
jacob that would be jacob's sons
his wives
his grandchildren and at that point he
had some great grandchildren probably
because
the spread of years between reuben and
benjamin is significant
uh so i think it doesn't count the
slaves that's unfortunate and when the
children of israel came out of egypt it
tells about them and then later it
mentions and there came out a mixed
multitude some of the other servants of
the egyptians escaped
so i'm pretty sure that there were more
than 70 people
that
came out of egypt i'm sorry i came from
israel to egypt but that's a great
question it does just mention i think
the family members
well pastor i'd like to give you
difficult questions thank you so much
yeah
that makes sense what do you think okay
all right hey thank you so much we
appreciate your call jerry thank you
jerry hey thanks scratch all right bye
bye-bye next we have robert from college
place washington robert you are on the
air
good evening pastor carlos pastor
bachelor hello
hi
hi there i
was
i found someone who believes
that
when jesus comes
that we will reign with him on earth for
1 000 years and um
we're just wanting to know how
i've used some verses but i just wanted
to know your take on
on that
yes
very good uh so during the the
millennium that's the thousand years the
word uh millennium is a composite of
if that's a thousand years same same
teaching
during that time there are good
christians that believe that uh the
living and reigning with christ and
pastor carlos will we're in chapter
revelation 20. which verse though does
it talk about we'll live and reign with
christ four thousand years verse four
the verse four thank you
yeah so they believe that means we're
living and reigning with jesus on earth
but the way they share that is
that at the end of the the rapture and
the end of the seven years of
tribulation jesus literally comes
and the righteous are reigning over the
wicked for a thousand years now i have
absolutely no desire to reign over the
wicked
um
some believe that we're living and
reigning with christ here on earth over
the wicked some believe that we're
living and reigning with christ in
heaven
my belief
this bible says
that
we are caught up when jesus comes
he says i go to prepare a place for you
and if i go to prepare a place i will
take you to where i am that you may be
also in my father's house are many
mansions we go up
and it's not until revelation 21 the
next chapter the new jerusalem comes
down
so
we are living and reigning you know
christ said we're reigning in the new
jerusalem with him
during that time testifying of what he
did to redeem us we're going to be
part of the iranians we're looking at
the records in the books
of what's happened here on earth
um
so
the idea that we're here on earth
reigning over the wicked where we have
immortal bodies they've got temporal
bodies where they die every 70 years or
80 years it's just a really strange
arrangement yeah and also says in
revelation chapter uh at the end of six
revelation 6 it says that the wrath of
the lord has come we know that the wrath
of the lord is the seven plagues of
revelation that are going to undo the
six days of creation
and so it would be impossible to live on
this earth after that time period there
would be nothing to sustain human life
yeah if you read in
jeremiah chapter 4 verse 23
and
pastor carlos you know that verse where
it says in isaiah i'll make the earth
utterly 24.
24. let me read first i'll let you look
that one up okay in
jeremiah chapter 4 verse 23 listen to
this
i beheld the earth and indeed it was
without form and void and the heavens
and they had no light well that sounds
like before creation
but keep reading i beheld the mountains
and indeed they trembled and all the
hills moved back and forth
i beheld and indeed there was no man
and all the birds of the heaven were
fled
and i beheld in the fruitful place was a
wilderness listen and all its cities
were broken down well what caused this
fruitful place of wilderness
everything's broken down
by the presence of the lord and by his
fierce anger now why don't you read your
verse and then i'll comment on that
isaiah 24 says behold the lord makes the
earth empty and makes it waste so if he
empties it it's because it was
filled and then it jumps to verse number
four it says verse 3 the land shall be
entirely emptied and utterly plundered
the lord has spoken the earth warns and
fades when you read further down verse 5
the earth is defiled under its
inhabitants because they have
transgressed the laws broken the
everlasting covenant and the curse has
devoured the earth and the the
inhabitants of the earth are burned and
then the last part of verse 6 says and a
few men are left
that word in hebrew shawar is like
genesis the the remnant right they're
those that are protected are sealed yeah
and then there's another verse where it
says uh there the land is covered with
the dead and there's no one to mourn
lament or bury malachi yeah is that it
so you have this several prophecies that
talk about a time when the earth is
vacated
and it's covered with the slain
and it's burnt
well that's after the lord comes we're
caught up we're living and reigning with
christ paul says the wicked are
destroyed by the brightness of his
coming
and
the earth is an abuso that word means a
bottomless pit
for 1 000 years it's a dark void
and we're living and reigning with
christ and glory at the end of that time
we come down and he makes a new heaven
new earth you know we have a study guide
that talks about a thousand years of
peace and maybe you could give the
number again we'll be happy to send you
jerry
or robert um a free copy of that if you
just call this number or anyone who asks
yeah
eight 1-800-835-6747
five
six seven four seven it's there on the
screen and you can ask for a thousand
years of peace i think it's called yep
talks about the millennium all right
thank you very much robert uh next we
have
jim from indiana jim hello you're on the
air
ah glad to talk to you again
um
my question is
in revelations when
the angel with the seven vials now is
that their
also the seven plagues
yes
it tells someone out and
yes go ahead
well i was just going to say those seven
uh those seven vials
are poured out and each one has a plague
so to speak
so it's like the wrath of god is being
poured out
now when did those start whenever they
enact the sunday law
well the the seven last plagues uh come
when probation closes and that's going
to be uh during a time when um
it tells us that
uh those that are saved or saved in
revelation 22 those that are lost or
lost they're clean or clean the unclean
or unclean
and when everyone's made their decision
one way or the other regarding the beast
in his image
then god is going to say okay no sense
for mercy to linger any longer everyone
has decided what they're going to do
and at that point the seven last plagues
are poured out so when the when they
reject
the law of god
um and they put the laws of the beast in
its place
then the plagues come yeah that's
exactly what we read in isaiah 24 it
says they have
humans have made their decision to
completely reject the covenant and the
law of god and so god says
i have nothing else to do they won't
listen to me i've given them ample
opportunity and so now comes judgment on
this world of sin but the yeah the
righteous are protected during that time
so when people hear about the seven last
plagues believers are often terrified
because they're very graphic
they're very much like the seven plagues
that came on egypt
and yet god preserved his people all
through those plagues
so we don't i don't ever worry about the
plagues
i'm more concerned with doug being
faithful day by day and if i'm faithful
day by day i know god will get me
through that time amen amen what does it
say psalm 91 neither will any plague
come nigh thy dwelling a thousand shall
fall out your left ten thousand at your
right hand but none shall touch you for
the angels of the lord shall be with you
that's right amen
all right now our next question here we
have uh
from david from new york david good
evening you're on the air
hello thank you for taking my call
and thanks for calling
yeah your question
yeah my question is what does the bible
say about two first cousins getting
married
all right well i think according to the
bible
it was legal in the days of abraham
because you have
what is it
jacob
married his first cousin when he married
rebecca
and isaac married
his cousin
i said isaac i should say rebecca jacob
first cousin with rachel and leah
and
in the beginning when you think about it
god made adam and eve they were
technically brother and sister same
parents
and then when cain took his wife
obviously he took one of his sisters
there was nothing wrong with that
abraham
married his half-sister
back when humans
blood and genes were so vital there were
no risks then of you know
having mutations that would cause
weaknesses and problems but as time went
by
moses said you're not to look upon the
nakedness of your sister
and he's insinuating that you know
you're supposed to marry out away from
the family tree as far as possible but
within the tribe are within the people
they weren't to marry foreigners
yeah and still today some people marry
their first cousins yeah and it depends
a matter of fact those states vary from
those laws vary from state to state but
there are risks because
i've done evangelistic programs on some
small islands in the south pacific
where there's not a big gene pool
and they have a lot of birth defects
because they're all kind of marrying
relatives and i've seen several times
where the kids or people had six fingers
on our six toes and that is one of the
signs of
um
you know
yeah exactly
so it's probably healthier to
look outside of the family
all right hey thanks so much appreciate
that david hope it helps a little bit
all right next we have uh ronald ronald
is calling from michigan good evening
ronald you're on the air
i think a screener may be talking to
ronald still okay let's go to the next
one we have chantel from
the beautiful island of the bahamas
hello chantelle welcome you're on the
air
good night pastor plaster caller hello
evening
hi
hi and your question tonight
can you hear me yes we can hear we hear
you do you can you hear us
yes i can yes i can
and your question no i have
i have a simple question um i have a
three-year-old niece um who is reading
and she asked me a question yesterday
she wanted to know how god made rain and
i was stumped to give an answer that was
suited for someone her age so i said i
will ask pastor da
um and bible answers live how they would
have answered
that question for three years
well that's a good question uh i'm not
sure exactly what happened with the
geology of the earth
uh or the meteorology of the weather
but the bible does say that before the
flood
that it never rained on the earth but
god did make a mist and there's several
places in the tropics you still see that
you know it's often it's it's very humid
you'll see a mist come up from the
ground and it watered the earth
and
but this envelope of water that god had
because it says he made the an
atmosphere heavens between the waters
above and the waters below there's some
envelope of water
and that's actually very scientific
because if you've got water that is
polarizing the light in the heat the
whole planet would have been a similar
temperature and they find
in siberia and antarctica they find you
know
fossils of ferns and these tropical uh
animals and they think that the whole
earth must have shifted on taxes or
something
but i think the whole world was a
beautiful habitable place
and what god did during the time of noah
to actually trigger
the flood i'm not sure but
he poked a hole in that envelope and it
just popped yeah it all came down and
but water also came up from below it
says the fountains of the deep we're
open so water shooting up and then from
then on there was so much moisture in
the atmosphere it began to rain
it's uh that would be genesis chapter
two verse six chantel and uh you next
time you go to the supermarket i don't
know if over there in the bahamas but
when i go to the supermarket you know
how sometimes they have the little water
mystery
genesis
so you can show them that and said this
is how god used to water the the the
nature in the before the flood
okay all right does that help that help
all right thanks
take care chantelle you have a good
evening thank you thank you
all right next we have travis from
lexington south carolina travis you're
on the air
thank you gentlemen good evening evening
my question is uh it's a two-part
question
is it possible to achieve a similar
state here on earth
and if it is not possible what are the
implications of believing that it is
possible
all right great question now i need to
let you know in advance we've got about
a minute so i'll do my best uh let me
ask you a question do you believe the
devil can tempt us to sin
okay do you believe jesus can keep us
from sin
now your answer is your answer is slower
so it as much as we believe the devil
can tempt us to sin we need to have
faith that uh with god all things are
possible
and that through jesus he can keep us
from sin so the fact is if you ask the
average church to be honest and raise
their hands how many feel sinless
nobody's going to raise their hand
because we all fall we sin and fall
short of the glory of god but we have a
perfect example and there's no excuse
for any sin and the lord can give us
victory over any temptation you can't
name a sin now unless it's the
unpardonable sin
but i know people who've overcome it
whether it's drugs or drinking or
cursing or whatever it might be
god can get victory every hour and we
need to believe that
now we're gonna we're gonna run out of
time travis and i'd hate to do that to
you but we have a book called is it
possible to live without sinning and
give him the number and we'll go to our
break yeah so
travis you can call
1-800-835-6747 and ask for that ask for
that book is it possible to live without
sinning and you don't let the title
scare you it is really a good book
that's great i actually read it once
when i was flying i put the plane on
autopilot and uh i was really touched by
it don't go away friends we're just
going to take a little break here get a
drink of water tell your friends to tune
in we'll be right back
stay tuned bible answers live will
return shortly
[Music]
turn on the news search the internet
stroll down the block
are you terrified yet every day brings a
new crisis in this coveted stress
society and it's not only external
disasters it's now in our very homes did
you know the bible told us thousands of
years ago that all of this would happen
join pastor doug batchelor for panorama
of prophecy a bible study spectacular
for more information visit
panoramaofprophecy.com
what if you could know the future
what would you do
what would you change
to see the future you must understand
the past
this intriguing documentary hosted by
pastor doug batchelor explores the most
striking bible prophecies that have been
dramatically fulfilled throughout
history kingdoms in time for more
information visit kingdomsandtime.com
would you like to know god's plan for
our broken world as revealed in bible
prophecy
want practical trusted solutions for
your biggest challenges
freshly updated and redesigned amazing
facts bible study guides provide 27
bible-based topical lessons with
beautiful graphics and straightforward
answers
that are enlightening encouraging and
easy to understand
each study guide leads you step by step
to real relevant bible answers for the
most important questions in your life
how can i have better health in
relationships
when and how will jesus come again and
so much more
don't leave the future to chance
transform your life with truths from the
amazing facts bible study guides
order your complete set today by
visiting afbookstore.com
or by calling 800 538 7
you're listening to bible answers live
where every question answered provides a
clearer picture of god and his plan to
save you so what are you waiting for get
practical answers about the good book
for a better life today
if you have a question about the bible
or living the christian life call us now
at 800 god says that's 800-463-7297
now let's rejoin our hosts for more
bible answers live
hello friends if you're just tuning in
this is bible answers live
and my name is doug batchelor
carlos munoz and we're here to try and
do our best to answer your bible
questions we don't claim to know all the
answers but we've got the bible in front
of us and we invite you to call in we
have some lines open if you want to call
the number is 1-800 god says that's
1-800-463-7297 with your bible questions
you can watch on amazing facts
television that's on roku as well as g19
satellites around the world
and you can also watch on the amazing
facts facebook page doug batchelor
facebook page
youtube
and you know i want to tell everybody
something coming up you know two and a
half three weeks
if you got a pencil you might want to
write this down
we are doing a full-scale
uh evangelistic program
that is going to go through the primary
teachings of the bible and it's called
panorama of prophecy we'll be exploring
some of the main prophecies from the
book of daniel and revelation
and there's a whole new set of lessons
we've just printed called panorama of
prophecy
that begins october 15
and it goes through november 13th
and it will be on
amazing facts tv it'll be on 3 abn it'll
be on hope channel and hope channel
international
and we're encouraging everybody to tune
into this special live study it'll be at
the new word center here in northern
california the amazing facts award
center and yours truly is going to do
his best to unpack these things so keep
it in prayer
go to panorama of prophecy.com
panorama of prophecy.com and you'll find
more details how you can
invite people into your home
or your church and say you want to join
us for a bible study
and they'll be blessed translated into
spanish yeah we've got a translator it'd
all be in spanish too
so we hope that you'll listen and
encourage your friends to do that all
right excellent so let's go back to the
lines we have uh brian you're calling
from hobbs new mexico you are on the air
brother brian
hi pastor doug i had a question uh
regarding
john 1 where it says jesus is the word
and my question is what does it mean
that jesus is called the word what does
it mean to call him the word
well and then yeah in the gospel of john
says the word became flesh and dwelt
among us
abstract thought is communicated by
intelligent creatures
through these sounds that we're making
that give us understanding of truth
and it's amazing you can close your eyes
and you hear words and you can have
pictures in your mind god conveys truth
through words
and the message of god to man was
communicated through the life of jesus
it's interesting we have no idea what
jesus looks like in spite of the typical
artist conceptions of what he looks like
what changed the world
was what jesus said
and
christ even said you know the things i'm
teaching this is going to go into all
the world
and he said you'll even be hated of all
nations for my name's sake and he knew
that that message would be a message
that would go global and it did
so
the message of god was in flesh he lived
out in the life of christ christ said if
you want to know what god's like look at
me
in the things he taught in the life he
lived
he was the message of god yeah you know
in spanish it's interesting it doesn't
use the word word it uses the word verb
jesus is the verb
so a verb is like it's more active yeah
it's the center of a sentence there's no
action without it so that's the
manifesto that's good yeah
so yeah and then even in um where is it
in revelation 19 where jesus comes
riding on a white horse and
on his thigh it says the word of god
and so that's a consistent uh title for
christ through the bible does that help
at all brian
yeah it does um so when we call when we
say that um when we call the bible the
word of god is it is it the same thing
or is that different
well the message of god is contained in
the bible and keep in mind when jesus
lived and he told us about the word and
reading the word
there was no new testament because
that's later written about his life
so
the old testament and the new testament
are certainly the word of god
and every time jesus was tempted by the
devil he quoted from the bible it is
written and that's where our strength is
it's in the word
all right hey thank you thank you thank
you we have a free book we'll be happy
to share with you brian and it's a book
that i wrote about the bible and it's
called the ultimate resource
and if you'd like a free copy of that
then
1-800-835-6747
1-800-835-6747 you can call and ask for
that book
all right all right next we have eduardo
from new jersey good evening eduardo
good evening pastor carlos good evening
uh that's doug
yeah um so i had a question on romans 9
um the whole chapter but just this one
verse where it talks about jacob i loved
isaac i hate it
who are these vessels of wrath fitted to
destruction when it says romans 9 22
what if god shows wrath make his power
not enjoy it with the much luck
suffering the vessels of god that is
destruction well first what is a vessel
he tells us earlier that you know god is
the potter we are the clay god can make
different kinds of vessels
um and so vessels are talking about
people he wants to fill our vessel with
his spirit
and he wants us to be vessels
uh containers that are for his use
to communicate his truth and to pour
ourselves out for good in the world
so we're the vessels when he says
vessels of wrath
he's talking about vessels that can't be
used now there's in the law of moses in
leviticus they had a law that said that
um
you know you could clean a vessel but if
certain vessels were exposed to anything
that was unclean if you opened up a
basket and had mice in it they said burn
it don't use it don't try and wash it
some vessels were to be destroyed
because they were unclean
and if we refuse to allow
the lord to clean us
we become vessels that are fit for
destruction but i actually want to take
you back a little bit because there's a
very common mistake that people make
when they read here in romans where paul
says you know jacob i've loved and esau
i've hated
he's actually quoting from malachi
where it says when he says jacob jacob
was a term meaning israel the people
esau meant edom are the
and the reason god said i love jacob and
i've hated esau is because
jacob he wanted the blessing and his
people
uh they were doing more to pursue god
the turned from god and turned
to paganism it wasn't that before they
were born god liked jacob and hated esau
god
like that jacob was pursuing the spirit
and esau was pursuing the flesh and god
heeded that that is still true today god
wants us to says in romans 8 if you live
under the flesh you will die
but if you live for the spirit you will
live so romans nine is expounding on
that yes and that verse is malachi
chapter one verses two and three yep for
uh eduardo yeah did that help eduardo
yeah i helped so much and i also had
just one more verse that what is like
proverbs 16 4 which says the lord had
made all things for himself yeah even
the wicked for the day of evil
yeah well god did not just say you know
i think i'm going to create some wicked
people so that i can burn them for
entertainment
it it's basically saying that i've even
created people who would choose
wickedness because i i create everybody
free
and so god made people with a free will
even lucifer god made a beautiful angel
he chose to become a devil
and so god is saying look i make
everything
he's the ultimate creator and he even
makes creatures that'll choose not to
love him
but the bible is clear god is good and
every gift of god is good
and god doesn't tempt anyone with evil
so god did not make somebody who would
deliberately sin or then god becomes an
accomplice
and just think about the implications of
that that god would make a creature that
had no choice but to sin and then he's
going to punish him for sinning it would
ultimately be his fault then yeah
yeah so we got to be careful a lot some
churches teach that that's a dangerous
doctrine all right thank you eduardo
our next caller is rolando from brooklyn
new york that's my my birth city orlando
you're on the air
hi thank you for taking my call
um like i said to the lady earlier um
first i want to say that i believe that
god knows everything that's happening
it's going to happen but that said now
judah's been vilified for betraying
christ but with god knowing everything
was that not his purpose in life wasn't
he destined to do that
no that's a great question and it's
connected with the former question
now think of it like this
god is a weather man just use this is a
rough illustration
and he flies in a helicopter
and from the perspective of the
helicopter he can see two cars heading
on the same road the the traffic signs
are out and they're going into a tunnel
and there's only one lane he can say
well there's going to be an accident in
the tunnel before the accident happens
he can see there's going to be an
accident he's not making the accident
happen he's just saying i know what's
going to happen
jesus
said i know judas is going to betray me
he didn't make judas betray him but god
knows everything so he knows what's
going to happen
he lets his creatures be free
and you know he he's
some parents have had kids and he said
this is a kid that just
is really rebellious and i kind of know
what direction he's going to go i don't
want him to
but that child has free choice
and god did not want adam to sin or eve
so because god knows something doesn't
mean he's making it happen
jesus he wept over judas he washed his
feet he longed to have him repent
but he just knew that he would
ultimately harden his heart yeah it's
proactive in hard decisions yeah exactly
amen
did that help roll on though
yeah i guess these guys okay all right
next we have uh safe from texas good
evening safety you're on the air
hi my question is how do we know when
the seventh last plague started
all right you know that's a good
question
one of the seven last plagues it says
the euphrates river would dry up i think
that's the sixth plague well he's very
interesting i turned on the news a
couple of years ago and cnn and fox
major news networks
they said the euphrates river is drying
up
because isis had captured the floodgates
up higher and they were turning them off
and the river was going dry and
basically trying to starve their enemies
and the folks were going oh that's the
sixth plague next plague is jesus comes
but now the water's got river's got a
little more water in it i do think it's
interesting that is one
that's one plague that may have a
literal and a spiritual fulfillment as
well but you know we certainly have not
seen waters turning to blood
uh you know we've not seen the whole
world covered with a noise and sore uh
yeah covet but not a noise i'm sore
and so i and then it says men'll be
scorched with great heat
and i think that's the fourth plague
and so um you know we haven't seen those
things happen i also think that the
the spiritual events that happened just
before jesus comes
talks about a law that everybody must
worship the beasts in his image or they
can't buy or sell and they'll be killed
that has not happened plagues come after
that yep and also there's there's no
repentance after the plague start to
fall
so some people ask is covered one of the
seven plagues well more people are
repenting now and and coming to the lord
than ever so that shows that we're still
we haven't gotten to that point it is a
plague and jesus said there'll be
pestilence in the last days so it
certainly fulfills that but i don't
believe it's one of the seven last
plagues yes exactly all right thank you
saith next we have edna from michigan
edna good evening you're on the air
good evening guys hi my question is
matthew 5 21
and 22.
so do you want me to read that or do you
want to you can go right ahead
okay
5 21.
you've heard that it was said to those
of old you shall not murder and whoever
murders will be in danger of judgment
but i say to you verse 22
that whoever is angry with his brother
without a cause shall be in danger of
the judgment
and whoever says to his brother raqqa
shall be in danger of counsel
but whoever says you fool shall be in
danger of hell fire
so my question is the very last
if if a person is a fool
and
what's wrong with saying that they are
hell fire is pretty drastic so what's
wrong with calling him a fool
uh yeah i know what you're saying there
and there are actually places where
james says
in um
oh i forget which verse it is but he
says
uh old foolish man
and then jesus said fools and slow of
heart to believe and if you read in
proverbs proverbs talks a lot about the
foolish man the fool is said in his
heart there is no god david said so are
all they they all going to hell because
they said that you know the word there
that jesus uses for fool it means they
call a person worthless and i think he's
basically saying that if you tell a
person that they're not worthy of being
saved that they have no value to god
um you know that's really an insult on
the creator
and uh treating people i don't think it
means sane at one time because that's
not the unpardonable sin but treating
people like they have no value before
god
um
that's yeah that's very dangerous
so what i hear you saying is
because god made that person
that
they are worthy
of his sacrifice and so therefore i
should not think him to be a fool yeah
or don't don't think him to be worthless
and you know even in english we've got
some words that depending on the context
they have two different meanings
and so this is one of those words in in
greek
that can mean a silly person and let's
face it there's a lot of silly people
their behavior
but then using that same word it can
also mean a person that has no value
and so you don't want to tell a person
they have no value
that's i think the context of what jesus
is saying
thank you i appreciate you telling matt
because i have i've read this over and
over and i just did not understand it
but now i do thank you
amen all right
next we have uh
ty diane tidian from illinois tidian
you're on the air did i say that
correctly
no
no i'm sure but you're not the only one
who's messed up
and how do we say it
it's a tavian
we're learning every day
and your question
um so my question is is that i'm in kind
of a predicament but the general
question is is the unpardonable sin
because i heard about this
i believe like a year or two ago
and it just kept clouding my mind and i
know and i essentially know what it
means and essentially
i know what it means i know how you
commit it but the thing is though is
that
i've been going through a lot of
struggles lately because i don't know
any other seventh-day adventist like
christians around me and even if i do i
can't go to church or whatever because i
don't drive but that's mostly due to my
fault
and the only really some of the
adventists i talk to are greg from bible
flock box and um
um mark fox from amazing facts through
the phone
but my question is is that if you
committed the important sin would the
character that god has
um been making you into still remain or
would it completely disappear
all right um
let me see if i understand what you're
saying so if you've committed the under
unpardonable sin are you asking does
that mean that you get any credit for
your past development
no no
no um no essentially
no essentially so like i'll do a little
bit of short story so that well we gotta
make we
see you summarize it as quickly as you
can because we got a few people left
yeah um so essentially so essentially
i've been struggling with sin a lot but
i've had victories over you know like
i'm emotion i don't play violent video
games much anymore
let alone any anything else
and i've gained the victory over
pornography essentially that really
doesn't bother me anymore
but
it's essentially got to the point to
where i asked god to put me through a
trial
and you know to bat on me with fire
basically meaning put me through trial
and then it later got to the point where
i think he did
and then i've been attacked mentally
that you know like
it's just like doubting god essentially
and then that's what led to me thinking
i committed the unpardonable sin and
that's just been plaguing me but for the
past couple of days i felt encouraged
and i even felt the holy spirit tug in
my heart on friday
saying go to jesus and then now
like the word of god is hitting me kind
of like what you brought up earlier like
with the destruction of sodom and
gomorrah i believe it was
something about abraham all right so if
if we were to summarize this are you
asking then
how do i know that i've not committed
the unpardonable sin
basically yes okay all right that's
that's a good question you know you're
not alone out there because people come
to jesus and they find themselves
struggling with sin for years sometimes
and well their whole life you're going
to struggle with temptation
but
does that mean then that well if i'm
still being tempted after being a
christian 30 years sometimes they fall
in the same area over and over again
does that mean i've committed the
unpardonable sin i'll say no
because
as long as there's a devil in the world
you're going to be battling temptation
you want to continue to nurture
the holy spirit in your life
when you are convicted you repent of
your sins and then by god's grace you
strive to turn repentance mean means a
sorrow for sin and a willingness to turn
away
do you see growth bible says grow in the
grace and and the knowledge of our lord
jesus christ
so you know are you seeing any progress
i'm encouraged because i see spiritually
that i'm growing i think i'm praying
more now than i ever used to and
and
i see progress in my life
but boy every day i was talking on the
way to the radio program with a friend
that picked me up i said i got a battle
every day with not eating too much
and it's been that way for years
because
you know if i just go with my taste buds
yeah i'll eat twice as much
so you're never gonna get away from
having
some battles and don't get discouraged
now we have a free book we'll send you
and it's called the unpardonable sin i
think you'll find that encouraging
tidion
yeah all right hey thank you for your
call we see if we get a couple more in
before we run out of time here yeah sure
let's go to uh
ruth from denton texas
ruth you're on the air
hello ruth
hi
[Music]
my question is
are those seven less plagues
going to be all over the world or like
separately in different areas areas of
the world
yeah good question um
you know even when the seven plagues
fell on egypt it seemed like different
areas in egypt had different intensity
the lord spared the land of goshen
during the last seven plagues
when it tells us that the earth is going
to be scorched with great heat
under the fourth plague i suspect it's
going to be worse at the equator
than it's going to be at in antarctica
and you know it talks about um
of course fresh water turning to blood
the sea is turning to blood
um
so you know i don't know that they're
gonna be universal in nature jesus said
that
except those days be short and no flesh
that means good bad anybody no animals
nothing would survive
so it's gonna be pretty serious yeah i
think they're progressive because if
they fell
on the on the earth that all
all covered the whole earth and that the
could be completely wiped out humanities
exterminate humanity so they're probably
going to be coming in different levels
at different time well i know they're at
different times
it's going to be a sequence
and you know maybe they'll just start to
recover from one and then another one
hits yeah just like in egypt yep
all right thank you ruth appreciate your
call all right we have uh kaleb from new
york colebrook welcome you're on the air
hello yes how you doing pastor doug
carlos evening
hello yes my question is about
someone asked me today and i was talking
bible with someone today and i couldn't
answer this question my question is what
about people that live in tribes um
people don't we don't know about jesus
christ
people because i remember a few years
ago
this guy went to try and preach to this
tribe and then
they killed him these people don't know
they don't they never heard jesus christ
what happened to these people
when jesus comes back okay that's
basically my question are you wondering
uh
is everybody lost who never heard about
jesus
and you know you've got these people
that are in you know they might be
aborigines in
australia or some of the natives in
the jungles of brazil or in africa that
never heard about jesus for all those
millennia
are all of them automatically lost
and i would say no
because you know jesus when he began his
ministry
he said
preaching to his
people in his own home church
he said there were many lepers in the
land in the days of naaman but none of
them was cleansed except the syrian not
a jew
and he said there were many widows in
the land in the days of elijah but
elijah wasn't sent to any jewish widows
he's sent to a phoenician widow
and jesus is emphasizing that there are
many that will come from the east and
the west and sit down in the kingdom
there are people i think in foreign
lands now most people are not going to
be saved jesus of the road to
destruction is wide
because they did not surrender to the
will of the lord but christ is pretty
clear in john and i think it's chapter
5 where he said the hour is coming in
which those that are in the grave will
hear his voice and come forth they that
have done good the resurrection of life
they that have done evil the
resurrection of damnation
there are some people maybe in foreign
lands
that
they're saved by jesus no one is saved
without jesus but they listen to the
voice of christ speaking through
providence or angels
and they they walked in the light they
had
there's nothing that would prevent god
from saving those people
so i think the holy spirit doesn't paul
say in romans 1
that even the barbarians who maybe did
not hear the gospel from an apostle or
preacher
they've heard god speaking through his
creation and so they're with without
excuse
so god has spoken to people
it's just never been as direct
missionaries are so important because it
is such a direct way of communicating
the full gospel but you know i think
there'll be some people that will be
saved from these dark corners of the
earth yeah and for god to judge
everybody as it says in the in the bible
then everybody had he had to reveal
himself in some way shape or form either
through creation romans one
uh through his son primarily through his
word so everybody in some way shape or
form has had a revelation of god yeah
and they've rejected it
or
acknowledged it and jesus said that if
you
had not seen you would have no sin but
now that you see your sin remains
so to whom much is given much is
required that people that know the full
gospel are going to be held more
accountable than those who've had very
little knowledge
of these things
all right you know what i'm looking at
the clock and uh i can't i don't think
we can do a question in 54 53 52. let me
tell you what's coming up friends don't
go away we are doing more bible
questions but just so you understand the
mechanics of this we're on
not only a number of land-based stations
in the internet around the world but
we're on satellite across north america
and the time clocks between these two
stations are a little bit different
we're going to be going off the air with
our satellite friends in just a moment
but everyone else stay tuned pastor
carlos and i are going to be going
through a number of rapid fire questions
in just a moment and if you want to
email email us we're going to be dealing
with questions that came in during the
email time if you want to email
questions to us
you can email amazingfacts at our bible
answers live address and say i'd like
you to answer this question
during your fast fire
program and at the end so coming back in
just a few moments with more bible
questions
thank you for listening to today's
broadcast we hope you understand your
bible even better than before
bible answers live is produced by
amazing facts international a
faith-based ministry located in granite
bay california
[Music]
all right we're back yes so this is what
they normally do during the bloopers and
the credits we're going to do questions
real quick we got like two minutes and
see how many we can get through past
across let's do quickly uh this is from
uh
joanne in england she says can you
please throw some light on jude 1 13
well there's only one chapter jude 113
we know that there is no eternal
damnation for the wicked yet the verse
seems to imply that god will punish the
wicked forever in a place of darkness
could you help me understand this
yeah well it's talking about um
it says for whom is reserved the
blackness of darkness forever well if
you get blackness of darkness it's
oblivion you don't see anything you
don't know anything and it's basically
saying that the wicked will experience
eternal judgment
uh they're you know
brought into non-existence the blackness
of darkness
and they don't see god they don't see
each other they don't know anything
and so
truth
and realization is compared to light
this is the opposite of that eternal
death
next on it has why was moses punished so
harshly for striking instead of speaking
while david was punished so lightly for
adultery and murder
well moses was treated um
severely because here is the leader of
the people the mediator between god and
man god told them clearly to speak to
the rock and god later said to moses he
said you're being punished because you
did not glorify me before the people.
and god ultimately did raise moses from
the dead and he did let him see the
promised land from mount nebo
david was punished harshly he not only
lost the illegitimate child he lost
three other sons the respect of the
people and uh yeah he spent seven days
on his face praying yeah
next we have mel asking my christian
husband left the church and had an
affair during the end of our marriage i
too started a short affair and committed
adultery will the lord judge us the same
for breaking the marriage vow
well all sin is sin but i'm not going to
be judging anyone's heart right now
because in a situation like this is
going to be a lot of circumstantial
evidence that our differences that
i'd recommend you read the book that i
wrote and you can send for it it's
called marriage divorce and remarriage a
lot of verses deal with that subject
there all right then we have here from
new zealand russell says
when jesus said he will be with us until
the end of the age does that mean he
will leave us at some stage i thought he
was with us forever
well yeah he will be with us forever i
think the time we're worried about is
not when we get to heaven i think the
context is the people were worried that
he was going to go to heaven and forget
about them he said no i'm never going to
leave you i'll be with you all through
the trials of this world and friends
wherever you are he's with you right now
and this really is
coming to the conclusion of our program
go to amazingfacts.org
[Music]
you